hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast sequence function mapping to
determine the impact of coding variants
I'm Rachel Brown of lab roads and i'll
be your moderator for today's event we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge this slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Doug Fowler dr.
Fowler focuses on developing and
implementing new techniques to address
difficult problems in protein science
and genomics he is currently an
assistant professor of genome sciences
and affiliate affiliate assistant
professor of bioengineering at the
University of Washington in Seattle Doug
did his graduate work at the scripps
research institute where he discovered
in character characterized the first the
malian functional amyloid protein during
his post doctoral work at the University
of Washington he began to develop
high-throughput methods for analyzing
the effect of mutations on protein
function I will now turn it over to dr.
Fowler for his presentation hi thanks so
much for that kind introduction I'm
excited to be speaking with all of you
today this is a new format for me so
thanks for making mistakes thanks for
bearing with me um today I'm going to
speak about a problem that my lab spends
a lot of time thinking about which is
how to connect the sequence on
of a protein to its function and what
implications that connection has four
variants that we find in in human
genomes so the first point that I want
to make is that coding variation is
pervasive in the human genome this is a
plot from a 2012 paper where 16,000
exons were sequenced or sixteen thousand
different genes were sequenced in about
twenty-five hundred individuals and what
you're seeing is the number of variants
per per individual on average in coding
regions and what you can see is that
first of all there are lots and lots of
coding coding variants so that's that's
the first thing the second is that if we
break those variants out by type we see
that the sort of easy to interpret ones
like splice variants and nonsense
variants where we can reasonably assume
there is likely an effect on the protein
and the northen and the synonymous
diane's where we can reasonably assume
that there's no likely not an effect on
the protein comprise only about half of
the all the variants that we see and in
fact missense variants comprise a pretty
large fraction and missense variants are
interesting because a missense variant
could range from having the effect of
complete loss of function to being being
in fact neutral one additional
interesting thing that came out of this
this work has since been you know been
sort of validated by many others is that
much of the variation that we see is is
rare and in particular the variation
that might be that might be functional
or might be damaging that's that's
overwhelmingly rare so what's true is
that interpreting coding variation is is
both challenging and important and it's
important because now it's really easy
and quite cheap to sequence a human a
human genome and people are as
sequencing moves into the into the
clinic and you know direct consumer
sequencing continues to grow people are
left with this question we sequence a
genome what we find there that's entry
it's evaluation right and people want to
know what are these variants do what do
they mean what do they mean for what
other disease or phenotype that I'm
interested in and so that's why that's
why interpreting variation is important
now making the connection between a
variant and a phenotype is also hard and
it's hard for a number of reasons the
first is that you know we'd like to do
is sort of gold standard genetic
analysis on all the variants that we
find in genomes but that requires you
know that requires that the variant be
fairly common such that we can collect a
reasonable number of people with the
phenotype and without and with today and
without and then an associate did I end
with the phenotype but that's really
hard to do when when variation what
we're talking about rare variants
because we just can't collect enough
people to do that type of Association so
the sort of rare variants which are
numerous and really hard to interpret
are a problem we've fought a lot about
and um there is there is a way to or
there a number of methods that can be
used to interpret these variants the the
one of which are sort of interested in
which we're going to focus on today is
by making those variants in and then
seeing what they do to the protein so
this is you know people have done this
for many decades um you can express and
recombinant Lee and recombinantly purify
the protein containing the day in
question or you can add a cell line such
that the cell line has the donate that
you're interested in and see what
happens and so these mutagenesis
experiments are a great way to
interrogate functional effect but they
do have one big limitation which is that
at least as they're traditionally
practiced they really don't have a hope
of addressing the vastness of sequence
space right so if we think about a
prototypical human gene which might have
7,000 variants possible suits single
mutations so possible signal singly
mutated variants but you know a person
could walk into a clinic or get their
genome sequenced and find any one of
those seven thousand but um but there
are you know a finite number of
functional experiments that you can do
you can only synthesize
many proteins and study them you can
only make so many cell lines and study
them and so while these approaches are
great they are sort of limited in their
ability to be deployed and then there's
another problem which is that you know
for all those there were 20,000 genes in
the human genome so you know we've got
7,000 variants by 20,000 genes it's a
really large number so that's sort of
the problem that motivates us and I'm
going to tell you today about three
distinct approaches to sort of getting
at this this problem so the first is d
mutational scanning which is a method
that we developed and are continuing to
to to work on which allows us to
interrogate the functional consequences
of variants on a very large scale the
second is envisioned which is a
predictor of variant effect that we've
developed that can be applied
genome-wide and which leverages this
large-scale mutagenesis data that we and
others have been collecting and then
finally I'm going to tell you about a
tool that we're developing that can
allow us to make libraries of variants
at multiple low sigh in the genome which
addresses is sort of an additional
important sort of biology and genomics
question which is how variants interact
when they're multiple at multiple rows
side so that's a sort of outline for the
talk today um so let's dive right into
deviational scanning so i'm going to
talk to you through a prototypical deep
mutational scan here and an idea of a
mutational scan is to experimentally
measure the functional consequences of
hundreds of thousands or variants of a
protein by marrying selection for the
proteins function to high-throughput DNA
sequencing an additional skin starts
with a DNA encoded library of protein
variants showing you an example library
here with four variants each one a
different color and we need to
instantiate this library in a system
where the DNA encoded variant is linked
to the is linked to the to the protein
value itself so a simple example of this
would be a culture of cells where each
cell gets a different plasmid and each
plasmid carries a different very
so when we put there are other examples
that we'll talk about that satisfy this
requirement so once maybe once we've got
our library we then impose a selection
for function for the function of the
protein that were interested in and this
selection could be anything from you
know asking the protein to bind a
partner to complement in the deletion of
this protein in the genome and imposing
this selection welp returns the
frequency of variance in the library
according to that ability to perform the
function so here you can see that the
red variant has increased in frequency
presumably because it performs the
function that we selected for quite well
whereas the blueberry has decreased in
frequency because it may be it's a loss
of function area so then the next thing
you do is come in with high fever DNA
sequencing and measure the frequency of
each variant in the selection both at
the beginning and a time points
throughout the selection and then at the
end and so what we've shown is that you
can take this high-throughput sequencing
data and develop a functional score from
it that recapitulates the biochemical
olfactive a mutation on the protein and
so this is just one simple way of
calculating a functional score and not
to suppose order to calculate an
enrichment ratio where the ratios of the
is the frequency of a particular right
after selection / the frequency of that
variant before selection so if the ratio
is greater than 1 as is the case for the
right of alien who would infer we would
infer that that that variant contains
mutations that enhance the function of
the protein whereas if the ratio is less
than 1 as is the case for the blueberry
of the movement and further that variant
contains mutations that are deleterious
to the function of a protein now we and
others have developed more nuanced ways
to generate functional scores including
taking multiple time points in
regressing or using flow sorting to sort
variants into bins activity-based bins
we have a software tool called enrich
that we're about to release a big update
to that can do a lot of this analysis so
anyway that's deep additional scanning
the point that I want to make sure
everyone appreciates is that this
process can allow us to ascertain the
consequences of hundreds of thousands of
variants for the protein that we're
studying which
that we can cover all of single mutant
space and get pretty far into double
mutant space um which which is a useful
thing to do so I'm going to tell you
about a couple of quick examples of deep
mutational scans just to sort of just a
sort of cement our understanding of the
method because a couple of the future
points of the top are gonna depend on it
so the first thing mutational scan we
did was of a small domain called a WWA
and you can see one here it's this three
stranded data structure in blue and WOB
domains in nature mediated
protein-protein interactions and in
vitro buying peptides and that's what
you see in the structure so we mean eyes
a 34 amino acid region of this WWE
introducing two mutations per clone and
then we close the library as an intra
infusion to a phage coat protein I did a
phage display experiment where our
selection where we asked that the
library bind to the target peptide for
this particular domain over several
rounds of enrichment we then sequenced
all of those rounds and calculated a
functional score for about 100,000
variants that were present in our
library we can look in the data and pull
out all the mutations single mutations
to alanine so if we plot those single
mutate the effects of those single
mutations here on the x axis you have
positional in an organized region on the
y-axis you have the log-transformed
functional score so the gray bar is
equal to wear what the wild-type score
is and each blue point represents a
measured functional score for a
particular alanine substitution so this
sort of recapitulates and alanine scan
of course we have the functional effects
of of most mutations at most positions
so we can construct a sequence function
map which is just a visualization or
visual representation of the effects of
all the single mutants on this domain in
the upper left hand corner you have the
alanine scan that i was telling you
about next door is cysteine aspartic
acid and so on and so forth so this is
sort of a visual way to see exactly what
the effects of all the mutations you can
make or most of them in this domain are
and there's an interesting biochemistry
story here
and and and and so on but in any case we
and others have shown that this type of
data if you set up the experiment right
correlates very nicely with with which
measures of the protein activity that
are developed using traditional you know
biochemical biochemical methods so
another key mutation will scan that I'll
tell you about the sort of procedures or
tells you a little bit about the
direction that were that we're hoping to
head or that we are heading is one that
was conducted principally by Lee
astarita this was a collaboration with
Jason dirty and Stanfield so so leah is
interested in brca1 which is a tumor
suppressor that's important in breast
cancer it's been studied for many years
but there are still a number of women
who whose brca1 gene is sequence and who
are given a diagnosis of uncertain
significance that is a mutation that's
ever been seen before and about which we
don't know really much of anything and
so our idea was to conduct a deep
mutational scan of brca1 and then to see
if we could say something about um to
see if we could say something about the
variants that are observed and another
interesting thing about brca1 is that
it's a multi functional protein so it
sort of mediates DNA damage repair um
that's a sort of high-level function but
it's also an e3 ubiquitin ligase and
binds to a number of binding partners
and so our idea was to decompose the
multiple sort of functions of PRCA one
or measure the individual functions of
brca1 and then combine those deep
mutational scans into a model it would
be predictive of this DNA damage repair
function which is important for tumor
suppression so we had developed a phage
based III deubiquitinating and then used
a mutational scanning to construct a
sequence function map where the function
in this case was the like about III
ligase activity she also developed a
two-hybrid based yeast two-hybrid based
barn one binding assay where the brca1
was being asked bind to bard 1 which is
a which is a critical binding partner
for brca1 in vivo so she was sort of we
were armed with these two mutational
mutational scams and
and one will get to the modeling in a
minute but first i want to show you
first i want to show you what this what
the what the sequence function Maps look
like for these scans um so here you have
on the top that III ubiquitin ligase
sequence function wrapping on the bottom
the bard one binding sequence function
map and these knots are organized in a
slightly different way than the one I
showed you before the heat maps where
each column is the position and each row
each row represents a possible amino
acid mutation that could be made and
more read a box is the more highly
functional not mutation is and more blue
the less functional so what you can see
here is that the two scans or the two
functions have some similarities and
also some differences and in fact
there's a whole interesting sort of
biochemistry story here that part of
which has been published and part of
which we're working on that tells us
about how brca1 sort of works but to get
to the point that I was talking about
before which is making a model to
predict um interpret it to predict DNA
damage repair in brca1 what we did next
was gather data on DNA damage repair in
a human cell model for 45 mutations and
then train a predictive model that
combined both III ligase and bottle on
binding data to predict the DNA damage
repair data and what you see here is a
plot on the x axis of the predicted DNA
damage repair in the essay and the y
axis the observed score and the red
points of the known pathogenic mutations
and the green points are the known
denying mutations and what I hope you
can appreciate is that our model
separates the benign from the pathogenic
quite well in fact it performs better
than any other on predictive algorithm
computationally rooted predictive
algorithm out there so this sort of
gives you a taste of where were hoping
to head with deep mutational scanning um
I will make the point that it's a
maturing technology so I told you about
a couple of examples but in fact there
are many this is just these
just some of them now you can use model
systems ranging from fate which we
talked about through coli and yeast to
mammalian cells the size of proteins
that can unionized has grown and is now
up to larger than the size of a typical
human protein about 500 amino acids so
that's very satisfying in my lab we're
working on a number of different
sequence sequence function not been
efforts one to look at resistance to
targeted cancer therapeutics um to to
examine other tumor suppressors and here
we envision doing t mutational scans on
you know the five or ten most important
tumor suppressors and then using that
data to try to develop genetically
rooted prognosis genetically rooted
prognosis and finally we're looking at
the activity of pharmacogenomic
important enzymes where we hope to be
able to predict dosing requirements
based on based on on variation that we
observe so that's sort of what we're
doing with the mutational scanning and
hopefully it gives you a sense of what
the what the technology can do but it
still leaves us with a big problem right
d mutational scans are great we can
comprehensively profile the effect of
mutations in a single protein but I hope
you can appreciate that developing an
assay and making the library and doing
all this sequencing it's expensive and
it takes time and although we're
dreaming up ways to do da tional scans
on a sort of organism wide level or sell
wide level or at least many many many
genes simultaneously we can't do that
yet and so we're still left with a
problem when we think about we think
about interpreting variants on a
genome-wide scale which is that you know
can't get to all the genes
experimentally so um that's what God is
interested in developing a computational
predictor of a variant effect and and so
that's what I'm going to tell you about
that's what I'm going to tell you about
next so variant effect predictors have
been around for quite a while these this
is just a partial list or a partial
graphic showing a partial list of
variant effect predictors in general
these predictors can do fairly well at
predicting the effects of mutations both
including regions and non-coding regions
and they they sort of work in the
following way so this is this is a this
is a panel from ippoliti polyphen paper
and it sort of just lays out how the
period works they're often very often
machine learning type approaches where
our training data set of variants is
gathered and that training goodness is
labeled often or pretty much all the
time it's labeled in a it's labeled in a
way where there are deleterious variants
and there are neutral variants so then
the model learns a way to classify
variants as either new banks that are in
the training dataset as either neutral
or deleterious and the way that's done
is by attaching to each variant a set of
features that inform the model can then
use to make predictions on variants it
hasn't seen based on the based on the
future values for that new guy so that's
how these predictors basically work and
what we observed was that they're
generally trained on these very large
very sparse data sets right so that this
is the polyphony example is instructive
there are about 50,000 mutations here in
the polyfoam training data set and
they're scattered throughout the genome
right so each gene in general we get
zero one or two training training
mutations in it and if you think about
it that's a very different type of data
than deep mutational scanning data so
the large-scale mutagenesis data you get
from adi mutational scan it's from one
protein but it's very deep sort of
comprehensively tells you about
mutations due to that protein and so we
sort of got excited thinking about this
I thought that perhaps we can bring
something to the variant effect
prediction space by training a predictor
on large-scale mutagenesis data that's
quite different from training data
that's been historically used to train
these types of predictors so objectives
in in this project or to collect the
public published mutational scans that
that other people have have done up into
our own and then annotate all the
variants in e scans with descriptive
features that we could use to train a
model and then in fact generate
predictive models based on the data and
see how they do um so I hope the sort of
first part of my talk convinced you that
we're sort of living in
of of high-throughput biochemistry or
can measure the effects of mutations on
many many a very large scale and this
plot spurred plot here is just the
cumulative number of single mutations
collected by deep mutational scanning
approaches in the last five years and
that's rapidly climbed to 35,000 if you
were to include multiple mutations than
his pot would go into the millions but
we restricted ourselves to single
mutations here because we didn't want to
be confounded by the effects of multiple
of multiple mutations in training our
predictor so the the proteins involved
in composing this data set are shown
here where you see the protein by the
number of variants on a log scale in
each data set for reasons that I'm not
going to go into to carefully the ones
in blue are the ones that we that we
chose to carry forward with as training
data for our for our model and I want to
point out here that it's a bit of a
rogue's gallery of variance or sorry of
proteins the proteins come from a
variety of organisms ranging from phage
to humans that are even some designed
proteins um that has been scanned and
and they are also all done by or not all
but mostly done by different labs
they're mostly done in different model
systems so some are scams using phage
display some are scanned and yeast some
are scanned in turn alien cells and many
of these scans were done sort of the
very early days of mutational scanning
when um you know sort of standards for
generating and analyzing the data or
less strong than they are now um and not
uh and that means that sort of it's like
I said it's a rogue's gallery of data
and so our thought is that if we can get
something useful from this data as a
training data set for a predictor then
things will only get better as we get
more data at more deep additional scans
in the future so anyway that's that's
the training data so there are 11
proteins in the end that we felt that we
could use and this is just um looks like
it didn't come through too well but
hopefully you can get the point this is
the 11 protein these are the 11 proteins
but we chose and these are just the the
distribution or histogram
of the functional scores for each of the
proteins there are 20,000 total total
mutations in this data set and we Center
the first thing we did was we centered
all the data at zero on the wild-type
wild-type so everything is centered
relative to wild-type for each of the
scams and then because we wanted to be
able to compare between and sort of use
as a collective training data all of
these different and sort of differently
shaped distributions we did uncle Alec
Fontella normalization to sort of
equalize the shapes of the distributions
and allow us to make comparisons between
between and across data sets so that's
the training data um we ought to
descriptive features that are not
particularly different from ones that
other effect predictors use you know
there's a deep literature of sort of
what works here and we went with what
works um we solely chosen a variety of
biophysical features that include facts
about the wild-type and mutant amino
acid we also when available use
structural information so I'll point out
that we generated models both that use
structural information and ones that
don't so we can make predictions on on
proteins without structures but when
it's available we use things like the
local density around the amino acid
that's being mutated the secondary
structure and so on and then finally we
include biological features like
evolutionary conservation which we know
to be a very important one and other
predictors of fact and then finally we
added domain annotations from from
uniprot and the reason why we have a
domain annotations is that we imagine
that in the future as more and more deep
mutational scans are constructed will be
able to make domain specific predictions
that are highly accurate right because
once we have a scan for a particular
domain I need him all I guess you know
domain in a different protein will
likely have a pattern of mutagenesis or
tolerance to mutations that's that's
fairly similar so that's how we include
a domain information okay so as a first
as a first sort of test of the way we're
training our model and the features that
we chose we decided to make individual
protein regression models and what I
mean here is the rather than mashing all
the data together to train a global
model we're going to try to train a
model just for
just on one D mutational scam for one
person and when I say regression what I
mean is what you're on Katrina model
that can predict the continuous
real-valued functional score that we saw
in the scan so not a classification
model like most other predictors that
can that can that can separate damaging
from neutral but a model that can
actually tell us what the score would be
with the score would be for each
mutation so um this is actually kind of
a hard problem if you think about it so
we weren't sure what would happen here
and what we saw in the end was that we
could could train a regression models
that were quite accurate so this is a
protein specific regression model for
Cobb won it's just it's just one of the
proteins from the scan you have in a
plot on the on the bottom the predicted
functional score on the y-axis I'm sorry
on the x-axis and the observed
functional score on the y-axis on the
y-axis and what you can see is that the
correlation is is quite high so the odds
square R squared value here is on point
86 and that um not suggest that our
model is doing an r-squared values
mentioned here and in other places are
going to come from cross validation that
we did in the model training um well you
can see what you can see is that the
model is uh is quite accurate so this
told us that the features that we that
we chose and a model training procedure
that we're using is a sensible one and
it also has one other interesting
corollary which is that we can use which
is that we can use the model to fill in
missing data or complete addy mutational
scan so this is the problem a data laid
out any heat map sort of like you saw
before we're only x axis our positions
of the meters knowledge region of pat
one and on the y-axis or all the
different amino acid substitutions you
can make and yellow means more
deleterious glue means less deleterious
so what you can see are a bunch of white
boxes those white boxes are missing data
missing data is a part of really any
deep mutational scan usually those you
know between five and fifty percent
missingness for a variety of reasons
um but since we had such an accurate
predictive model what we figured we
could do was actually fill in the
missing data using on model and of
course this assumes but the data that
we're missing is no different is no
different in kind anyway then the data
that we have and I think that's a
reasonably good assumption but in any
case we can use we can use these protein
specific models to complete deep
intentional scans which is useful if our
goal is to use G mutational scan to
operate on a particular on a particular
protein and make predictions so this is
just a plot of r-squared values for a
number of different protein specific
models that we made and you can see that
some of them are about as good as have
one others we going to do so well and
we're not sure here whether this is a
this is a result of data quality or some
deeper sort of biochemical truth about
the protein that makes it more sensitive
to mutations or less predictable but in
any case this is a good sign that our
that our modeling process is working
well so we next move on to a more more
challenging problem what we wanted to
train a global regression model so here
our goal is to now mash all the training
data sets together and train a model
that can predict and then we do identify
we do identify that the training data so
the model doesn't can't learn from which
protein the training data came right now
we want to train a general predictor a
variant effect from these 11 from these
11 d mutational scanning data sets and
again we're trying to train our
regression model meaning we want to
predict the actual functional score of
each mutation and this I think is a
really really hard task if you think
about it what we're sort of asking is
can we learn how to predict the
magnitude of effective own mutation
accurately across a range of proteins
that are pretty much unrelated so it
turns out that we can train a global
regression model that performs pretty
well in cross-validation so what you're
seeing here is the r-squared from cross
validation for the mall it's about point
seven which is satisfyingly high a
question that we were interested in
asking is one of the important features
of this model in other words what
features are the most informative and we
find just like many others
found but solvent accessibility and
conservation are the most important
features in our model so that's really
no surprise now when I show you in our
squared value from cross validation you
know that's it's nice to see but it's
not really what we actually don't want
this model to do which is make
predictions on a data set that the model
has never seen at all and so to sort of
see what would happen if we if we tried
that we trained the global mall where we
left one protein completely out of the
trainer and then asked the model the
model that was trained on the other ten
proteins to predict what were the
functional effects of that of that one
left out protein and we see that we can
do it sort of so we get an r-squared
value of point four four beta lactamase
other proteins are sort of in the range
if you are better any are worse than
this one and so what this means is we
can predict with some accuracy the
functional explorers of a protein and I
guess this model would work on sort of
any protein that you that you that you
that you fed it but I don't think we can
claim that this is really working well
enough to say we've we've solved the
magnitude effect prediction problem and
can just go out and predict that
effective magnitude of any substitution
in any protein but I do think it hints
how as we refine our modeling procedure
and get more data will be able to maybe
we'll actually be able to tackle this
problem which would be really fantastic
and provocative if we could do it um so
given that we retreat into a slightly
more modest task which is now just
training a classification model so again
a global model works on all the all the
protein data sets that we collected
intended to predict the effects of
mutations on any protein but now we're
just going to classify proteins into
either de lutera variance in the other
deleterious or neutral okay the first
thing we have to do in order to train
set remodel is discretized our deep
mutational scanning functional scores
and we did this using the synonymous
distribution a variant available in
these deep mutational scans we've been
talking about the nonsynonymous variants
that we get from D mutational scanning
but we also in many cases get synonymous
variants sort of for free based on how
the libraries were created
and and you can see this anonymous score
distribution on the right hand side here
for you pick the ubiquitin G mutational
scan just as we would expect it's a very
narrow distribution because synonymous
variants don't tend to have functional
consequences so we use the bootstrap to
construct a ninety-five percent
confidence interval on the synonymous
variant distribution and then use that
confidence interval to classify a
nonsynonymous variance as either
damaging or other so now we have our
training data for a classification model
so the classification what the
functional sport discretization looks
like for a number of the other proteins
in that in that in the training data set
you can see that in general we have more
damaging than other mutations to
different degrees with different
proteins so that can this can be a
reflection of data quality and there are
some sort of deep issues that we don't
have time to get into here but this is
what this is what we saw uh so we went
ahead and trained a global
classification model and saw that it was
eighty eight percent accurate and
cross-validation again solve an
accessibility and conservation are the
most important features but moving on to
the sort of gold standard test which is
how long does the model work on data
that the model hasn't seen at all we
left out each of the five proteins that
you see there train classification
models and this is just the accuracy in
cross validation for those models and
what you can see is that no one data set
makes a big difference or not leaving no
one dataset one left out and this is a
big drop in model accuracy which is a
good thing when we then plot the model
the model accuracy on prediction for the
on the unseen data set we say that we
get quite high accuracy in most cases
which is really great right that that
tells us that our model is actually
successful in predicting in predicting
the effects of variants are classifying
variants in tie their damaging or
neutral for protein that the model has
never ever seen which is great um so we
called our best model envision and I'm
just going to show you a few more
comparisons now between envision and
other predictors on a number of
prediction tasks so this is a comparison
that's like a little messed up sorry
what the rocks at the y axis is supposed
to say is a ec so it's area under an ROC
curve which is another metric of model
metric of model accuracy and what you
can see here is that for the www dataset
envision performs way way better than
three other commonly used three other
commonly used models which is a very
nice thing to see um we wanted to use an
independent data set that we didn't
collect to validate our model and we
turned to that date for that data set to
the protein database which is a database
of over 100,000 mutations curated from
the literature by a group in Japan and
these are these are these mutations have
been um these mutations have been cited
in a biochemical way so we know what the
biochemical effects are and they were
classified into a bunch of different
classes ranging from neutral to complete
loss of function so this is a nice data
set to test the performance of ignition
on for this test we took the neutral
mutations as neutral and then anything
classed as Villa teria strongly
deleterious or complete loss of function
as damaging and then we compare
envisions prediction capability to the
prediction capability of a number of
other predictors and this is just an
honor a seeker of Sean what happens so
envisioning is more accurate than then
every other model that we tested except
for one and that snap snap is slightly
more accurate than envisioned but it's
also not a fair comparison because snap
was trained on this on this this
particular PMD data set so it's sort of
hard to hard to make a comparison in
that case in any case what this tells us
is that from nine protein deviational
scans we can train a model that is at
least as good and in many cases better
than other variant effect predictors out
there so that made us quite happy so the
final thing we wanted to know was
whether envision could improve
pathogenicity predictions so you've been
talking about biochemical effects up
till now right that's sort of what
envision is for that's what the data
sets its trained on or biochemical
effect data sets most other models are
trained on on predicting pathog variant
pathogenicity
from databases like clinvar that have a
bunch of mutations that are classified
as either pathogenic or not um so we we
examined envisions predictions on
pathogenicity or on pathogenic variants
in clinvar and this is an ROC curve
showing you but envision doesn't do very
well in pathogenic pathogenic variants
which is no surprise because it's not
how we trained it but what you do see
it's interesting is that if you added
vision to a the best-performing model
that in our hands which is CAD you now
get a combined model that's even better
than can certainly better than any of
the other models and this tells us that
awning sort of biochemical effect
predictions to these pathogenicity
predictors can actually gain us a little
bit of extra mileage in predicting dire
effects which is which is a cool is all
my thing um okay so that's that's
envision our chronic at effect
prediction which I think has turned out
quite nicely we're hoping to make it
publicly available in the next month or
so via website and a paper so finally
I'm going to use the last 15 minutes or
so 10 minutes or so my talk to talk
about this issue of combining variants
at multiple no signs so up until now
we've been talking about individual
proteins right but we know that
interactions between Valiants a
different loci are important for human
disease so if we think about genome-wide
Association studies there's sort of this
issue of missing heritability has come
up and what we mean here is that when we
look at the tips that are considered
significant in most Jewess they don't if
you add them up explain all the
variation but are all the heritability
sorry about particular disease or trait
and the missing heritability there are
many hypotheses about where where it is
but what idea is that it could be
combinations of variants and multiple
low sigh that caused this this missing
heritability in G wasps analysis so
another example is in cancer but cancer
many mutations are acquired by cells but
then go on to become cancerous and the
order in which these mutations are
required in sort of how they are
permitted and combined on
can have big implications for aggressive
the cancer is and how you can treat it
so we're very much like to be able to
study interactions between low sigh and
experiments away but this turns out to
be hard to do so if we think about um if
we think about a sort of simple
experiment we might want to do when
there were five low sigh and 10 alleles
at each locus we have a thousand
combinations to make and this is too
many to make um using sort of
traditional certainly using traditional
methods but even if we turn to sort of
the gold standard way of editing genomes
now which is cast nine and in case
you're put into a rock gasps nine is a
is an onion guided and nucleus that can
make on site specific double-stranded
breaks and then we can use we can use
homology directed repair about
introducing a template with virology
arms to repair those breaks and put in
variants that were interested in this is
great all this is great the problem is
that cost nine is not particularly
efficient especially when it comes to
HDR and if you and if you start thinking
about editing multiple MOS I this
inefficiency becomes prohibited very
quickly so imagine that we had to really
highly efficient Cassadine guides and
HDR cassettes where we could get ten
percent HDR each locus right that means
the only one percent of ourselves would
be doubly edited that is how edits at
both of the two low side we were
interested in and really one percent is
not enough to one percent does not
appear enough population to do the types
of biology or screens we would like to
do to study how variants at each locus
influence the effective variance at the
other so what we thought about was
trying to make a reporter to detect
successful genome editing that would be
scarless on the message and/or protein
level because we don't want to give up
our advantage of endogenous locus edit
completed there would be site-specific
and multiplex abul so in thinking about
this we came up with a design of a
synthetic intron that could mark editing
at any any locus that was near a coding
a coding region and the idea of the
synthetic intron is that we would how to
repair template that we could just
contain our desired edit or edit could
be elaborate about it
and then we would have a synthetic
intron that would sort of either replace
a natural intron or just be introduced
into an exon de novo and that's
significant Ron would be able to express
a fluorescent marker so then what happen
what would happen and i'll talk about
the design of the intron in a minute so
don't worry about it too much but if we
can make such an intron work and what
would happen is only how r 6 what would
happen is that our successfully edited
cells will become fluorescent and we
could then flow sort for the edited
cells if we think about how this would
work in a multilocus fashion it's pretty
easy to see that we could mark each
locus with a different color so that
multiple e-edit in cells would be flow
sortable based on their multiple
coloration or multiple in fluorescence
so that's the basic idea behind what
we're trying to do and on the design of
the synthetic intron that we came up
with overcomes a few of the key problems
that come up when you start thinking
about what you would need to make an
intron that could express approach and
so this is the design of the intron that
we never made we started with with actin
and we started with the third intron of
actin and co-opted the three plot the
third intron splicing owner and splice
acceptor sites from from from the octant
intron three now introns are not
particularly stable so we're going to
stabilize our synthetic intron because
they get they get spliced and then D
branched and rapidly degraded so to
stabilize our synthetic intron we stole
a couple of viral sequences RNA
sequences that generate these big nodded
and helical structures that prevent
degradation by exonucleases so this was
our way to stabilize the intron the
synthetic intron so now that it's stable
we've got to get it out of the nucleus
so it can it can encounter our ribosome
and and be translated so to do not we
stole another dial sequence which is a
consistent of transport element that
gets RNA sequences out of the nucleus
finally we add an internal ribosome
entry site and an egfp coding region
which which if all these other elements
work right and the intron disabling it's
under the nucleus should enable the
ribosome to find and translate this is
sort of
synthetic message that we've created now
he interrupted the actin or with the
third with this synthetic intron and
also appended an M cherry I sort of a
reporter for correct octant slicing so
the first thing we tried was seeing if
this synthetic intron would function on
a plasmid so I'm showing you here
untransfected cells this is flow data
where you have the M cherry signal on
the y axis that gfp signal on the x axis
and then histograms of each signal so
you can kind of see where the points are
in the scatter plot you see that there's
not much signal from on transfected
cells that's good when we trim spec
cells with often and it's natural third
intron just to make sure nothing gets
screwed up there we see the expected M
cherry signal but no gfp signal so no
synthetic intron when we now trans fact
often with the synthetic intron in it we
very pleasingly see that we get both em
charlie signal an gfp signal and this
suggests to us that our synthetic intron
is getting is getting transcribed and
translated but it could be that the
message is never being spliced right and
that the full-length message with the
synthetic intron in it so that gets out
of the nucleus and then the iris signal
just leads to gfp expression even though
there's no splicing which would be a
very bad thing that was happening so
what we did was delete this just the
splicing elements from our synthetic
intron construct and that's now shown in
the central panel and what you can see
is that when you delete just the
splicing elements you now get not only
do you get um no m Charlie expression
because it's not a frame but you also
get no gfp expression indicating that or
at least suggesting but splicing has to
happen in order for us to see the GFP
signal that marks that marks the or that
indicates that the GFP signal that comes
from this medic intron so um so that's
sort of told us that things were working
as expected on the on the plasmid and so
the next step then was to ask could we
actually see this make this work in a
genomic context so we did the obvious
thing which is take our actin construct
and use cos ninety HDR to recombine this
construct into the genome so now what we
have is a population of cells in which
we replace the third intron an octave
with our synthetic intron cassette note
that M cherry has been completely
removed from this genomic this glue be
removed from this genomic synthetic
intron construct so the isolated a bunch
of cells grew them up for four weeks to
dilute any remaining plasmid which of
course will still express both markers
and then isolated single cells to create
chronal lines uh this is how the
parental cells look when we flow sort
them so just as you would expect there's
no I'm cherry signal and there's no gfp
signal which is which is comforting now
if we look at this up so when we when we
look at the club's that we got we got
two phenotypes one phenotype is lots of
gfp signal no i'm gerry signal let me
interpret to mean the b cells likely
have our synthetic intron we combine
into the correct location in acton where
the synthetic intron is now being
transcribed as part of the as part of
the initial transcript spliced out and
then export it from the nucleus and and
the gfp translated so we got some some
clothes that look like this we also get
some clothes that look like this well we
see both GF p and n cherry we were
expecting these types of clones and this
is just essentially random integration
of the plasmid into the genome right
where the plasmid of course contains
this is an intron and also the act in a
ton cherry fusion so we were expecting
to see this and comfortingly what's true
is that other ten clones that we've
isolated so far eight are gfp-positive
mj- that is the thing 1 and 2 are
gfp-positive i'm very positive that's
that is the thing we don't want but in
any case I think this demonstrates the
basic idea works right we can you can
make a synthetic intron that's stable
that can express a gene which is I think
a pretty cool thing and we can use that
gene dot dot marker to select cells that
have been edited at the locus in
question so now what we're doing now
what we're doing is um basically showing
that we can use this at multiple loose i
and that we can actually put in
libraries on each locus and get and get
out the desired product which is a set
of cells
have been edited at multiple Louis I
simultaneously so so that's that's the
synthetic intron project and really
that's what I wanted to say today so I
hope I've convinced you that on there
are a number of sort of interesting
methods that can be used to try to make
connections between the sequence of a
protein and its function I also showed
you a little bit of data about how that
dot sequin that sequence function maps
can be useful in interpreting variation
we find in human genomes do unit a
Chanel standing is kind of found its
lags and i think is becoming widely
applied and we're excited to sort of see
where it goes i told you about a vision
which is an accurate variant effect
predictor but we've developed which is
trained on a different kind of training
data than other very [ __ ] predictors
and we argued could be useful for
different purposes finally I told you
about this synthetic intron business
where our goal is to construct
multilocus libraries of variants and so
with that I want to close by thanking
the many people who did this work so in
my lab the D mutational scanning work
was so spearheaded initially by Jason
stefani on the brca1 data that I showed
you was generated primarily by me esta
Rita and Stanfield lab and not project
was also a collaboration with Jason
dirty for the envisioned the
computational predictor that project was
spearheaded by Vanessa gray our guys
student in my lab in collaboration with
Ron Haas and with assistance from ian's
knew back in JC under Islam and then the
synthetic intron story actually started
as a rotation project from a very
brilliant rotation student Molly
gasparini in the genome sciences
graduate program and it's been continued
by a postdoc in my lab can attract so
with that I'd like to thank all of you
for your time and attention and say that
I'll be very happy to answer any
questions that you might have great
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question answer session I would like
to remind our audience how to submit
question
you can submit questions by typing them
in the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can right now it looks like we don't
have any submitted questions so with
that we can go ahead and wrap up this
presentation today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
November 2016 you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting year when the
was when the webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye